thank you Paul thank you for the
introduction thank you for the amazing
work you've been doing with Cass
over the last two or three years thank
you to Anna Hogg for all the
administrative work that makes it
possible for people like me to stand
here as if by magic the biggest question
that I want to have organized my talk is
how the major media corporations use
images of piracy as they work to shape
the ways that we engage the world we're
soon going to have another chance to
find out because on May 20th Walt Disney
Company will be releasing on Stranger
Tides which is the fourth in its famous
Pirates of the Caribbean series
following on from the curse of the Black
Pearl in 2003 Dead Man's Chest in 2006
and at World's End which some of us
thought might be the end in 2007 just
before I go any further how many of you
have seen the first of those films curse
of the Black Pearl oh wow okay that's a
big help how about the second one okay
how about the third the real diehards
well actually this is a pretty good
cross-section of global responses the
first one was extremely popular even
more popular than Disney had anticipated
the second one in fact reaped the
largest financial reward for them of the
trio it was so bad that by the third one
even though it promised to conclude the
series audiences fell away and I can see
that many of you did too it's a labor of
something not necessarily love to plow
through all three but let me just
mention briefly my interest in these
films and the reasons for it it's really
at the convergence of two projects one
quite specific and one more general the
specific one is I'm interested as a
teacher of global histories about how we
can use Hollywood film to more
effectively engage students interest in
not only images of the past but the ways
those image
past get used to promote particular ways
of engaging the present and films like
this are a great way of meeting students
where they are and then trying to take
them into areas they've never been
before specifically in that regard as
Paul mentioned ie
when I first came here used Peter
Linebaugh and Marcus Reddick has brought
many-headed Hydra which has as one of
its central chapters a powerful
description of the role of communal or
democratic forms of rebel piracy around
the Atlantic in the late 17th early 18th
century a theme that Marcus elaborates
on in more detail in his later book
villains of all nations and so when I
was teaching this I had to say something
about the pirate series and I have done
endlessly even after I've stopped using
this book so that's part of my concern
but as Paul mentioned I also have a
broader set of concerns and that is to
ask how it is that dominant forms of
cultural production orchestrated by
mainly by major corporations and allied
politicians have been relating to the
transformations in the workings of
capitalism oh that the last 30 or 40
years as they've been played out within
the boundaries of the United States and
particularly interested in the idea that
capitalism always depends on particular
ways of shaping people's attitudes and
commitments and that if it changes the
ways it works it renders its old methods
anachronistic the question is how then
in varied forms might capital be trying
to reorganize the kinds of subjects that
it produces what I want to do in the
context of both of those projects is
asked four questions today the first one
is what has the series brought us the
second one what does it mean and then to
add two questions to the flyer why
should it matter and finally where can
we go from here
especially as we turn from what we've
seen so far to the new film will come
out on May 20th
the argument I'm going to make very
broadly is that while these films are
certainly entertaining and I think
especially for a target audience of
teenagers and people in their 20s
they're not just escapist entertainment
they're also and perhaps more
significantly they're a way of using
images of 18th century rebel piracy to
incite or perhaps more accurately excite
a conformity to particular corporate
visions of how we relate to life to
labor to leadership in the world at
large among the multiple challenges that
the present offers us my aims in making
this argument are to offer resources for
thoughtfully engaging the new film for
pushing against the limits of these
corporate visions as that as they're
promoted in the series because I think
some of those visions are seriously
confining and restricting not to say in
some cases threatening of the ways that
we live and think about our daily lives
and more generally to suggest some ways
of thinking more creatively about the
cultural politics of contemporary
capitalism before proceeding I just want
to get a few points in quickly that I
hope will help you as you engage what I
go on to say the first is that I'm
interested in the films as a window into
the visions that corporations are
promoting and the stories that they used
to do so this is not about either the
conscious intent of the film's authors
or the film's actual effects I think the
question of effect is something that we
can only work out through detailed
ethnographic analysis so I'm interested
in these films of what they tell me
about what corporations are telling us
and I don't think that when corporations
spin their stories they're necessarily
doing so with some conspiratorial intent
rather they work with in particular
partly taken for granted assumptions
about how to engage audiences where they
are with the problems that they face and
the interest they have and suggest ways
of addressing those interests and
concerns in ways of the congruent where
they taken for granted set of
assumptions about how capitalism should
work today secondly I want to say that
there is of course an element of
playfulness in all of this it is the end
of Tom after all and
it's our fun but I also think there are
good reasons for taking a series like
this seriously first of all I think we
need to take very seriously the dominant
forms of cultural influence that operate
the world we live in
and to recognize that those are some
times that they're most powerful when
they come disguised in the form of
entertainment and especially escapist
entertainment secondly Disney is among
the world's leading five global media
conglomerates and of course has been the
most powerful media conglomerate for
many years in trying to shape the
attitudes of young children and their
parents and what these films represent
is an attempt to move into a much larger
audience of late teenagers and people in
their 20s so we need to take very
seriously what it is that Disney is
saying this was its big rival to the
Lord of the Rings and Harry Potter and
Disney in fact invested huge amounts of
money in creating these stories and then
making sure that they would be seen and
heard moreover what I want to say is
that these films and the stories that
they tell while I think they're
interesting in themselves are mainly
significant because of the ways that
they resonate with stories and images
being told elsewhere and offered
elsewhere that if the stories themselves
were out there on an island unrelated to
what was being said in other context
then I think they would have much less
power
what really renders them powerful is the
ways that they echo and refortified
stories that are being told in other
forms such as in major magazines and in
the management literature that has been
generated since they late 70s to try and
suggest how companies should reorganize
themselves but also reshape the
attitudes of their workers the context
of major changes third thing I want to
say is that I've deliberately couched
this talk in a way that I hope can reach
the widest possible audience so I have
backgrounded a number of theoretical and
conceptual issues that I would be happy
to discuss at the end of the talk and
afterwards but also I wanted to do it in
such a way as to convey not only some
resources
can use to make sense of these movies
but also where I think the fun can lie
not just in watching these movies
uncritically but the new and different
kind of pleasure that you can watch is
you begin to see what's going on in the
midst of the entertainment I remember in
my early 20s as I began to learn how to
reread the things I was watching through
a more critical eye how much fun it was
to both enjoy the movie and to think
critically about what it was saying in
its relation to what was going on in the
wider world final thing I want to say by
way of introduction is that this is very
much an abbreviated perhaps someone
should say a skeletal version of a much
longer argument and I'd be happy to
flesh out parts of what I say in
discussion including particularly as
regards to theoretical and conceptual
issues that are woven through but lie
beneath the surface of what I'm saying
finally of course it's very much a work
in progress it's very much open to your
input and feedback and I'd be grateful
for any thoughts that you have so with
all of that said what if this series
brought us so far what I want to suggest
is that they have brought us three
interwoven narratives the first
narrative is about personal relations
it's about the relations between
Elizabeth Swann and Will Turner
Elizabeth the daughter of the Governor
of Jamaica attracted to will but will is
a working class artisan and the problem
of their attraction is that will doesn't
seem to have the kind of daring
necessary to break through class
barriers to woo Elizabeth and in that
context Elizabeth becomes attracted in
some way to Jack Sparrow to be Captain
Jack Sparrow the pirate and so a
triangular relationship emerges between
the three of them in which will then
also has to work out his relationship to
Jack's piracy and then the knowledge
that his father was in fact a pirate so
that's the first kind of triangle the
second set of relationships involved is
between the Pirates as a whole and the
British elites as they govern the
Atlantic
in the first film as you know governor
Swann and Norrington by the second and
the third added and then ultimately
displaced by Cutler Beckett the head of
something called the East India Trading
Company very thinly veiled version of
the East India Company of course and the
question the fundamental question in
some ways through the films from the
point of view of the Pirates is who is
going to control the Seas or how at
least can they overthrow the control
that oppressive British elites are
exercising over them that comes to
implicate Elizabeth and will as you know
in all kinds of ways but there's a
fourth element in these films and that
is the relationship of all of these
people to characters called Tia Dalma
who we later know his Calypso and to
Davy Jones and although they are
particular characters they also quite
explicitly are said to stand for the
Seas for the different forces that
operate in the sea so there's a kind of
ecological thread going through this as
well about how humans beings relate to
nature in both its destructive forms
associated with Davy Jones and it's
potentially more liberating forms as
associated with Calypso now what I want
to suggest is the sometimes dizzying
storylines as they unfold through the
three films are in fact anchored by the
continuous repetition of this structure
that these positions remain constant
throughout the three films moreover
they're anchored by an emphasis on
particular kinds of groupings and
particular kinds of themes this is just
from curse of the Black Pearl the very
first of the films but what it suggests
is it isn't just a relationship between
particular people it's a relationship
between categories of people between
British elites and pirates but also new
class terms between elites and
intermediaries and subordinates
Elizabeth subordinated by agenda will by
class and that what is at issue here is
partly the theme of love and hate trust
and deceit but also especially in the
struggle of the pirates to gain control
at least freedom of the seas the stress
but the tension between life is
represented and freedom as
for Jack by the Black Pearl and
constraint and death represented by the
curse in the first film of the Aztec
gold now these films they think through
this structure tell stories that are
explicitly pedagogical they set up
dilemmas for their central characters at
the beginning they then complicate the
situation further and then offer partial
resolutions those partial resolutions
then set up new dilemmas new
contradictions and new resolutions and
you know repeat as needed I mean that's
the great thing about a franchise like
this this formula based on those kinds
of structures can go on forever but
within that framework the pedagogy's I
think are very important what they
suggest to us is not only what we should
aspire to through seeing what it is that
the heroes aspire to but also how it is
we should get there we see the main
characters learning better how to get
what it is they want from those we see
those around them learning from what the
central characters do and as audiences
we are asked to learn from the learning
that is going on and more specifically
what's emphasized at least what I want
to tease out for our present purposes
are four kinds of action that are meant
to help move us towards a resolution of
the dilemmas and the complications and
do that for the characters and offer us
lessons in the process tells us what's
valued by both Hera wising particular
kinds of action and establishing
contrastive forms of demonization in
relation to people who are held to be
they're impeding these activities or
doing them quote the wrong way the first
category I want to look at is what the
films have to say about life in general
and in particular the idea that to live
properly in a world like this you need
to be skilled at making deals but making
deals isn't just about a bargaining for
your own immediate advantage what we
learned through the film is that those
who just do that get into trouble that
what you need to do is you make deals is
so no with whom it's appropriate to
build trust and with whom it isn't so
just very briefly the very beginnings of
the film Jack arrives as you know in the
port the first thing he does of course
is strike a bargain with the harbour
master
bribing him three shillings to be able
to dock he then of course then steals
the money for him that's the role of the
contracted version of a deal it's unlike
most of the others because most of the
others involve a deferral the promise of
something down the road in return for an
advantage in the present Elizabeth we
see when she's taken on board barbosa's
ship it tries to make a deal realizing
she has something of value the medallion
the Aztec coin that he wants but it
turns out she's not very good at making
a deal and instead of letting her free
he takes her with him we'll then turns
up once he realizes she's been taken and
comes to Jack in jail a man who
represents a kind of piracy that will
hates but decides that he has to make a
deal with Jack because the authorities
are not willing to make deals in order
to go and rescue Elizabeth from the deal
is of course that in rescuing Elizabeth
Jack will be able to get back the Black
Pearl that has been stolen from him so
the idea of deal-making and forging
trust is absolutely at the center here
and it's contrasted all the way through
with the rigidity and hierarchical forms
of the British rule as represented by
Swann and by Norrington and then of the
complete unwillingness to be flexible
and to trade back and forth shown by
Cutler Beckett so both positively and
negatively here we've got a valorisation
of us of a crucial skill the skill of
being able to make deals and to
understand a particular kind of what I
want to call a grammar of action in
which it's not just you blindly trust
anyone else but you work out a kind of
selective ethic in which you know who it
is you can trust and who it is you can't
trust it big is by the end of the series
okay to cheat the people who are bad but
important to trust and make lasting
compacts with the
for who the film represents as good the
second kind of action I want to
highlight is around labor the argument
here is that as Jack and will set out to
find Elizabeth on the black pole and
repeatedly throughout the series people
try and get what they want not only by
making deals but especially forms of
will and Jack and later Elizabeth by
either forming or joining crews and
setting out to work hard to get that
what they want in the face of constant
challenges and pressing deadlines these
crews are characterized in a quite
specific way as flattened hierarchies
Jack is the captain Gibbs as the first
mate and then people like Marty cotton
and in the first film Anna Maria as crew
members a certain level of hierarchy but
real informality compared to the other
crews the Royal Navy crews the crews of
Hector Barbossa on the Black Pearl in
the first film the the crews of Davy
Jones in the second and third film are
by contrast once again extremely
hierarchical rigid top-down control not
through inspiration or charisma but
through oppressive violence from the top
thirdly leadership although the films
suggest that you get things done by
making deals and forming teams to go off
and work together intensely to get
things that you need it led by visionary
leaders leadership is not suppressed in
the ways that we know from the work of
people like Marcus Redeker was true of
communal and democratic piracy in the
late 17th early 18th century those kinds
of piracy were explicitly committed to
the notion of communal ownership control
of the ship and whatever it gained
pirate captains were elected and led at
the will of the members of the crew
these films retain a notion that
captaincy and more generally leadership
is important
what they emphasize is that that kind of
leadership must be not simply from
people who have inherited a position or
qualified it through for it through
official channels but instead have
gained the right to lead by appearing as
natural leaders through their vision or
charisma and once again the contrast is
really explicit Hector Barbossa has
gained captaincy of the Black Pearl by
stealing it through a mutiny Davy Jones
has a fact obtained the flying dutchman
by betraying Calypso and in Carla
Beckett's case he simply rules by brute
force and pure economic calculation
repeatedly he says that what he's doing
is just good business I think this is
actually very important because we've
heard very often that in this day and
age what capital encourages is to do to
be what it's often called neoliberal
subject people guided by an economizing
logic of calculative rationality in
pursuit of our own personal interests
not only in the world of work or the
economic sphere but across all spheres
of activity these films quite explicitly
represent that as part of the problem
and suggest a different way of
interacting with people if you want to
get things done the fourth kind of
action that I want to talk about has to
do with what the ultimate goals of all
of this might be this is not a story
about how to fit in with a world that
already exists these are stories about
the capacity of world making and what
stress particularly in the second and
the third films is that people are
struggling to free the seas and in this
process free themselves by undoing the
control first of all of the moderately
benign but nonetheless rigid and
hierarchical British authorities
represented by Swan and Norrington
and then later to free themselves from
the brutal tyranny of people like Cutler
Beckett and the company that he
represents so time and again what we
hear is that the search for freedom
isn't just a personal search for freedom
through something like the Black Pearl
or the freedom to woo and marry whoever
you want within society but a larger
social freedom that liberates the sea
from authoritarian rule and that also
opens up the ecologically the productive
part of the sea represented by Calypso
by killing off the threats that are
represented by Davy Jones now in that
context I think it might be helpful just
to look briefly at the way that the
first film concludes by pursuing all of
these kinds of actions against people
who are acting very differently at least
a partial resolution is achieved Hector
Barbossa is killed Elizabeth and well
big surprise
get to unite and are about to be married
Jack meanwhile gets to escape gets back
on to the Black Pearl looks at this
compass and works out where it is that
there will be going next so what we are
asked to think by the end of the first
film is that faced with particular
dilemmas and constraints people pursuing
good forms of deal making the right
kinds of intense labor with a crew under
the right kinds of leadership will be
able to free or at least open up some
space to freedom within the existing
system by the end of the first film it's
a compromise in fact what we what we
hear from Weatherby Swann when Jack has
escaped is this he turns to Norrington
and he says about whether they should
pursue Jack right away perhaps on the
rare occasion pursuing the right course
demands an act of piracy piracy can it
self be the right course and I think
what's being said here is not that they
see should be surrendered to piracy but
the British rulers have to learn that if
they want the world to be a better place
some kind of synthesis has to be
achieved between the various kinds of
respectability represented by will and
Elizabeth and a kind of spirit of piracy
not as theft but as daring and a
willingness to bend and break the rules
represented by Jack once we get to the
end of the third film the resolution has
a little more complicated what in fact
has happened by the end and I'm sorry
this is a spoiler for any of you who are
waiting with bated breath to know what
happens the entire upper hierarchy has
been killed off one way or another Davy
Jones has been killed off the evil
pirate Xiao Feng is dead Barbosa has
converted at least partially to better
forms of piracy and so the world is left
in the hands of Elizabeth and well Jack
and Barbosa and Tia Dalma as Colette so
now released and very simply Calypso is
released Jack excuse me well has taken
on the captaincy of the Flying Dutchman
the ship that was initially charged with
taking the souls of people who died at
sea into their final resting place a job
that he that Davy Jones had abandoned
and will now takes over what that means
is he has to be at sea for ten years at
a time and can only come on shore once
every 10 years so in fact even though he
and Elizabeth are now united they can
only see each other once every ten years
he has to go off to work constantly
leaving her at home moreover in Disney's
notion of sexual procreation well kisses
Elizabeth on the knee and that leads to
her getting pregnant and so nine months
later she bears a son but will will not
get to see her until ten years later
well Elizabeth and
the son patiently wait for him to appear
on the horizon meanwhile Jack and
Barbosa seemed to be free to escape in
the Black Pearl
but Barbosa reverting to his old
character steals the map that will lead
to the Fountain of Youth a central theme
in the fourth film and thinks that he is
going to be able to escape on the Black
Pearl with the black Paul's crew and
leave Jack behind but then we learn
right at the end that Jack has in fact
taken out the very center of the map and
can set off just as he entered on his
own small dinghy in the free seas to try
and find the Fountain of Youth okay what
does all of this mean well I'll be able
to tell you better if I get my notes in
order what it all means is something
that I think obviously is open to
interpretation but what struck me when I
first watched these films was how much
of what they were talking about echoed
language that was being valorized or
images that were being valorized about
what it meant to be an effective person
in the world today in various kinds of
management literature I was reading
something that also came out in 2003
which was Andrew Ross's book no collar
based on ethnographic research he did
with people in new economy workplaces in
New York I was reading Stephen Klein a
towels book called digital play about
the video game industry and the lives of
people who work making video games I
mean actually designing them not the
people who labored to produce the
material content and I was also later
led to Bolkonsky and Kia pillows book
which also came out in English
translation in 2003 called the new
spirit of capitalism which includes a
very extensive review of what the
management literature's of the time was
saying about how managers themselves
should change to catch up the new
condition
and how it was that they should get
their workers to change and what struck
me as I saw the film in conjunction with
reading these texts was that how much of
what the film values under the image of
rebel piracy with all its historical
associations with communalism and
democracy was in fact a kind of
conformity to the imperatives of the new
kind of corporate capitalist discourse
as expressed through things like the
management literature to get at that I
think we first need to unpack a number
of obvious contradictions or at least
apparent contradictions in the workings
of these films first of all of course
Disney has made its name as a provider
of wholesome family entertainment and
yet this is a film whose central
character is modeled on Keith Richards
of The Rolling Stones is socially
dissolute sexually ambiguous and so on
and so forth so what is Disney doing
with this kind of a character as it's
one of its central figures secondly of
course Disney is a major global
corporation working very hard especially
in the 1990s and 2000's to extend itself
globally by whatever means possible and
yet the most demonized entity in the
whole series is the East India trade our
trading company under Cutler Beckett who
is exactly trying to extend the global
reach of the East India Trading Company
by whatever means it can and thirdly of
course Disney films valorize a certain
kind of piracy and yet Disney is
notorious for most aggressively
asserting its intellectual property
claims and prosecuting those who seem to
infringe on this a contradiction or
apparent contradiction captured by it
for anyone who watches the videos
because the first thing you see is of
course is the FBI anti-piracy warning
that proceeds the titles and then the
introduction of these heroic pirate
figures now all of these will seem like
significant contradictions but what I
want to suggest is the in fact those
concurred
or losery first of all I'm gonna pause
just a moment I wish this were rum but
but it's not first thing to say is as
regards the first of those
contradictions Disney first of all in
some very interesting ways has never
been pro-family values and anyone who
looks at the way it represents
motherhood or more accurately the
complete erasure of motherhood from its
content will understand the complexity
of its relationship to a pedagogue er
about family values but also caused by
trying to reach this teenage and early
twenties audience expand its reach
beyond children and their parents young
children and their parents
it was quite deliberately a taking on a
more risque association with fading Rock
store stars in the sort of bohemian
artistic an artisanal way of life
secondly what I think is going on around
the demonization of a big company trying
to be global is a kind of self
immunization what Disney I think is
saying through a film like this is well
there are ways that you can try and be
global that we should not approve of but
by implication that Disney is able to
produce a critique of this it can't be
that kind of company and thirdly as
regards piracy Disney remains largely
aggressive in its assertion of
intellectual property rights but like a
lot of firms especially around video
games has come to learn how it can
actually appropriate the labor of people
who pirate its goods through checking in
on how it is that having taken their
video games they've reworked them people
constituted in the language of Klein and
others when they talk about the digital
play as prose humors that is people who
are consumers of the goods even if
they're pirated but also producers of
ways of making those games better that
the big companies then essentially
utilize labor the people provide freely
that the companies can then utilize to
make their games better so Disney in
fact hasn't been
aggressively anti piratical in all the
areas as you might think but more
crucially of course what it's doing is
its shifting the goal posts its defining
piracy for its purposes in these films
not as robbery or theft but as daring
rebellion the willingness to bend or
break the rules in the pursuit of a
higher good and so what I think we see
in these films is the attempt to hijack
a particular set of images of rebel
piracy and in fact use them to induce
conformity to a particular corporate
visions about how people should fit
within the demands of a new world in the
making that new world is one that
created enormous stresses for people
during the 1980s and the 1990s these
films were being where the first one was
being made in the early 2000s what was
the world in the United States like for
most people by that point
well between ninth first of all enormous
material stresses on people between 1973
and 2000 the bottom 90% of households
saw their real income declined by 7
percent while the top naught point
naught 1 percent saw their incomes rise
by 600 percent
moreover the ways people responded that
declining household income was to
increase the amount that they worked as
indicated here in the space between the
1970s and the 2000s the average u.s.
household increased its total labor by
at least a month and this is a context
in which of course some people are
taking on huge amounts of labor other
people are desperate for more work but
can't get enough of it 40% of people in
the growing number of part-time jobs
actually need full-time jobs but can't
get them but the total number of hours
goes up social benefits of various kinds
either provided by the state or by
employers are being cut back massively
this
Church the growth in the number of
people who are uninsured in this context
people have to spend more and more of
their money buying resources that they
might have previously been available to
them as entitlements to do that they
take on more and more debt both consumer
credit card debt and mortgage debt so
what we have here is Disney putting
together a film in a context of a
restructuring process that's been
unfolding since the 1970s with the
promise that it would increase
prosperity addressing an audience at
least in the United States but in fact
in many ways globally as well that is in
suffering increasing stresses partly
around the question of labor and how not
only how you should act in the workplace
but how you should deal with demands to
work harder and harder without
significant increases in pay but also a
situation in which people increasingly
were told that you cannot rely for what
you need on either the state or your
employer when things get tough you have
to let rely on privatized and
personalized forms of networking and
that I think is a key to understanding
what it is that the film's valorized and
heroines for us to take what I talked
about initially as life labor leadership
in the world at large what we see is
that in fact the films as an
intervention in a context of increasing
stress about how to live one's daily
life and more generally of course a
crisis of legitimacy for the wider
restructuring project suggests to us
that through making deals in a trusting
way one is in fact doing exactly what
the management literature says we should
learn to do which is to become flexible
networkers people who can continuously
reconstruct our relationship with others
while at the same time what the film
does time and again is it takes this
kind of imagery and reinforces it
corporate discourses played out through
management literature but also
tries to reform I so it says yes
flexible knocking networking but not as
a cynical manipulator of other people
but instead as Jack loans to become an
Elizabeth and will are those ethical net
workers who know who to build the
relationships with and how to do it
properly
secondly as regards labor the pursuit of
rebel piracy by forming crews and a
flatten hierarchies and going off and
working intensely to get one's goal is
of course a direct echo of the logics
demanded of workers in the new workplace
the logics of project oriented labor by
rapidly assembled teams working under
extremely intense deadlines where they
work as long as possible and as hard as
possible in order to get the job done by
the deadline in which the boundaries
between home and work collapse in the
favour of work all of this is in fact
what the pirate crews under someone like
Jack are doing and it's contrasted with
the soulless living-dead labor of
working in the cruise of Davy Jones and
Hector Barbossa
but what's added here is the idea that
this kind of labor instead of being
exhausting and enervating should be seen
as exciting exhilarating and ultimately
in the social good moreover what we see
echoed through the idea of a certain
kind of captaincy a sort of charismatic
captaincy is exactly again what you see
in the management literature that says
the old top-down forms of management
control should be abandoned in favor of
flatten hierarchies and charismatic
leadership but what these films do is
they say yes but only if that kind of
leadership can be owned by the right
kind of people if it can be earned then
people should follow and finally we get
this notion of the free seas very much
echoing the notion that the world we
live in today is a fluid and mobile
world a space as manuel castells called
it a space of flows and in fact time
again the metaphor is used to describe
the contemporary world as it has been
created our liquid metaphors so taking a
story to see and asking it has to how to
live on the Seas becomes a crucial part
of a broader story
what suggested here is that what people
are doing is not simply adapting to a
new world but making that freedom
through the ways in which they live
labor and accept particular kinds of
leadership and that's contrasted to more
oppressive ways of running a global
world as represented first by Weatherby
Swann and Jack Norrington and then more
vividly and more threatening ly by
Cutler Beckett and the East India
Trading Company why does all of this
matter well I think you've gathered from
what I've said already that I think
these films are very much about inciting
or I might say through the action
adventure mode exciting a kind of
conformity to a particular set of
demands about how we rule retool not
only our actions but our ambitions and
our understandings of the labor that we
do for our employers but also in our
wider lives in ways that in fact are
quite threatening but before I get there
let me just talk a little bit about the
ways in which these films seem to
suggest a sort of heroic role for all
their major characters but in fact are
highly selective in doing so and so
doing actually it employ a number of
powerful silences and erasers that
undermine the rights of everyone
involved to feel like they are equally
capable of participating in this system
cut broadly what we see is exciting
conformity through privatized
individuated transient connections just
a second oh okay let me just go back to
this quickly um I did a last minute
switch
slides the reason that I have those
three images up there is this first of
all on racial issues the film is really
striking in the fact that although it's
set in the Caribbean in the early 18th
century and it's about control of the
Seas it doesn't mention why the British
might want to control the Seas that is
of course they were becoming the
dominant power or were to become soon
the dominant power in the control of the
slave trade moreover in portraying
governor Swann as the basically
Honorable Governor of Jamaica they were
neglecting the fact that Jamaica had
from the late 17th century been the
leading destination for British slave
with slaves that the British obtained in
order to work and sugar plantations that
the wealth and prosperity of the Swans
and the wealth and prosperity that will
will marry into is based on slave labor
moreover and perhaps more crucially in a
way that is repeatedly true of Disney
films there is a complete erasure not
just in this case of slavery and the
slave trade but of production in general
these are films about the world of
circulation they never asked how it is
that things get produced under what
conditions there's a similar Oratia that
i've already alluded to as regards
gender in these films the most striking
thing is that until the very end and in
fact after the final credits of run on
at the world at at World's End
there is no representation of a single
living mother nor in fact of a single
living wife and in fact Elizabeth's fate
however much she's been heroine in the
movie as someone who could take on the
world of men and act creatively in it is
eventually a reward is to stay at home
looking after the kid while her husband
is away 10 years at a time getting on
with the job
and moreover doing so in a way that is
designed to help save his father so
restoration of a particular kind of
patriarchal male line that leaves the
woman staying at home looking after the
kid but more generally and what's more
important is that this is the only time
we actually see a mother in the whole
and second erasure is involved here just
like the omission of slavery is not only
racist it's also an erasure of
production so it is here that we've a
narration of reproductive labor once
again we're never afforded an
understanding of the material laborers
that go into making possible the
privilege that is enjoyed not only by
the Swans but by people like well and
then finally the working classes
eventually become pirates in that sense
they're freed from the constraints of
other more hierarchical forms of labor
but they're always represented as people
who must be led who could never aspire
to be anything other than the kinds of
workers that they already are all they
can aspire to is a better leader one way
of looking at all of this then will be
to say that it's about prejudicial
exclusion from a prize worth having what
I want to suggest go back to the slide
I'd begun to talk to you
there's an in fact what's really
problematical is that the prize that
others win may itself be a problematical
thing to aim for that what we're asked
to think about when we look at private I
where we look at flexible and ethical
networking is yes a reliant on the
ability to build relationships of trust
with other people to get things done but
very much in the notion that we can
aspire to nothing more that we cannot
aspire to having a social system that
ensures through the state or through
employers that everyone is taken care of
it's now a matter of individuals working
it out for themselves in the case of
Labor that yes we're going to have to
keep working and yes it may be exciting
but we are going to have to deal with
the fact that it's going to be
incredibly long hours exhausting
conditions finite jobs the end of a
secure career the growing emphasis on
sequential jobs with often limited
rewards the one of the things that Ross
and Klein both talk about is when they
looked at the new economy workplaces a
lot of people were given stock options
and thought how great that was something
like the apparent sharing in communal
privacy of the distribution of what was
gained in the end those stock options
almost in very
turned out to be worthless because the
companies went under moreover the wages
of people working in those companies was
significantly less than the labor that
was enjoyed by people in more stable
hierarchically organized institutions
and so what they were doing was they
were accepting the promise of excitement
in return for a significantly lower wage
with infinitely extensible almost
infinitely extensible working days terms
of leadership what was also found in
these companies was people thought that
they were exciting because the
hierarchies had been flattened and
because if leaders emerged at all they
emerged because of their vision and
inspiration and transiently but what
they found was that when push come to
share push came to shove with the
dot-com crisis but leadership reasserted
itself and that the inequalities that
they thought had been erased from the
workplace were viciously reasserted when
it came to working out who should be
kept and who should be fired and more
generally in terms of the world at large
what I want to suggest is that the film
in suggesting a goal of freeing the
small entrepreneur if you like the small
pirate from the constraints of those
above is in fact taking one part of a
dialectical movement in capital over the
last 30 years which is on the one hand
to fragment production through
outsourcing both to factories and to
consultants and service providers but to
do so at the same time by massively
concentrating power in the hands of a
small number of corporations what the
film does is flatten out that double
movement into a single movement in which
the world that these kinds of activities
will produce is representing as
producing freedom for lots of small
operators so finally then where can we
go from here
I've subtitle this rival piracy and
constructive critique very quickly what
I want to suggest is that first of all
we can think about ways of understanding
the cultural politics of capitalism
today that go beyond a concentration
that we've seen in a lot of work that
says that the only real problem
is a problem of overall legitimacy or
consent and that we need to focus on how
it is the capitalists are trying to get
most people to go along with the system
as a whole to me that's only one part of
the story it's certainly in there but we
need to ask how it is that cultural work
encourages support for particular
versions of a project but what Disney is
promoting in a way is opposed to what
certain other kinds of major
corporations are promoting or at least
seems to be but it's still trying to
gain support for a particular vision of
what will continue to make capitalist
labor seem emancipating but just as
crucially is what I would call here
shaping our attitudes about the conduct
of our daily lives now quite a lot of
people have thought about this but
they've mainly thought about it under
two headings either the image of the
consumer citizen so the function is how
more and more of us are encouraged to
think of ourselves as consumers in
relation to markets rather than citizens
in relation to the state there's
certainly a lot of that going on but
it's not enough just to focus on the
refashioning of people as consumer
subjects another way that because what I
want to suggest is a lot of work is
going on to reshape our ideas about work
about personal relationships and about
political action in fact the for almost
invariably inseparable incitements to
work in different ways are attached to
incitements to be able to consume in new
ways and to support particular kinds of
political project often all related to
back to what it means to be a good
husband a good wife a good father a good
mother and so on and so forth so we need
to look at the shaping of attitudes
across all of those areas another kind
of approach I'd want to ask us to push
beyond is the notion that there is a
promotion of a single kind of subject
appropriate to all of those kinds of
activities we've seen this in the
language from people taking out fuko's
work or neoliberal government allottee
around the notion of the neoliberal
subject that suggesting that what
capital encourages is a subject who will
calculate meticulously his or her
advantage not only in the workplace but
at home as regards the family in
consumption and everything else but what
I think I find when I look at lots of
movies from the last 15 years or so is
in fact that most of them constitute
that way of being human as in fact
dehumanizing and seamed therefore to
address the concerns of many people that
it's dehumanizing but do so in such a
way that they nonetheless excite
conformities to other forms of a narrow
vision of what it is to live and at the
same time do so not around the notion of
a single right way of doing things but
in differential ways ways that a class
differential race differential and
gender differential finally what's the
next film going to look like what would
happen if we were to bring these ways of
thinking to a critical engagement with
the next film well I can't be sure about
what the films going to look like but
I've read as much as I can get my hands
on and what I what seems to be the case
is that the structure is going to remain
very much the same this is the structure
I showed you before what it looks like
we're getting now his jack is still
there or boasters still there but he's
now working for george ii will and
Elizabeth have disappeared Angelica is
there she it turns out as the daughter
of Blackbeard I put a question mark down
there because it's not true whether sure
whether he's going to represent piracy
struggling against an alliance between
the crown and a next pirate or whether
in fact he's up there in the realm of
magic but we certainly know there are
going to be mermaids and zombies I don't
know whether this is still at a
missionary is going to turn out to be a
love interest of Angelica's we do know
that Jack and Angelica were previously
involved what they're now trying to get
their hands on is the Fountain of Youth
the thing that Jack was searching for at
the end of the third series what I do
know whether this kind of structure is
repeated or not is that we need to ask
ourselves as we watch these films how
very entertaining we may find them as we
watch the new film in particular what's
going on while we're being entertained
what kinds of subjects are we being
asked of value what kinds of work and
labor living and leadership are we being
asked to support and what does that mean
in relation to the world as we actually
live it what I want to suggest is that
we need to approach these films with a
third definition of what rebel piracy
might be involved not theft not bending
and breaking the rules in the service in
fact of a reconfigured form of capital
but as people always willing to
critically ask questions about and
challenge the assumption that we should
live with the world as it's given to us
that's it
you